[Music]
hi I'm Dave Anthony I'm here with Gareth
round say I invited Gareth over to watch
a cartoon
this one's maybe my favorite cartoon of
all time
did you remember Tom and Jerry Jerry I
remember Tom and Jerry talked about a
little guy no it's a mouse it's a mouse
and a calf Spanish twist this is called
a Spanish twist with Tom and Jerry
sometimes they play hobos is this before
they came a mouse in a cab don't worry
about like some of the greats
I mean that's a big note right off the
bat jirô gonna be a cat and a mouse
instead of a tall and short guy don't
get stuck on that you won't be able to
get into the flow so typical opening at
cartoons the middle ocean octopus so
they've obviously dropped acid right
yeah and that's not a lot of people know
octopi have many tactics why would you
underwater what he's attacking you go to
what you know you know land guys I think
you first need is check your underwater
ladder okay so that's how we get moving
in the ocean this is a documentary now
they're in a place huh so say from the
other in Spain yeah oh so they they took
three tidal waves to Spain it was faster
than typical mariachi group
oh yeah it's not a house it's don't lie
so she's asking them to the ground
yeah very Spanish they do it to they're
drinking the kool-aid so now it's just
dancing my t-shirt
Oh No imagine they hit a curmudgeon and
he's got balls on his side well it's
pain he's a prick they already fought
the bulls are they gonna fight the
Chicago Bulls okay okay so now they're
gonna be mad at doors
nights those are heroes so these are
just guys who go about their life with a
yes and sort of attitude yeah okay well
fight bulls for the princess that we
just met and then these are the boss
okay
oh Jesus a lot it's a lot of bulls they
have a North Korean army buddies they do
loops in Spain yeah okay the thing about
cartoons is once you draw some you might
as well just keep using it Sharon a
while now this is pretty classic
bullfighting stuff right here
oh the upside down the opposite pyramid
yes the knees well but that guy's gonna
not thank himself in the future I would
think at this point you'd be like we're
not good balls okay first of all it was
a bad game plan and there was like eight
of them and now 30 dropped so they have
swords with them outside to go for yeah
yeah a fist fighting there's a lot more
fist fighting both spent less time
planning how to march out and more time
with a battle plan this could probably
be going a lot better for them whoa we
got an old it's a message oh
it's yeah got Chuck from the heels it's
a guy from the Spanish gold silver
special delivery
wait the eighteenth Amendment
prohibition is over my friend
I thought slavery for a minute
so they go to Spain just for the moves
oh it clearly there in the United States
that's the dinging so they're pretty
excited yes finally a reason to go wait
yep what just happened
well what you did was you took a you
took a tour of Spain I did and you got
to see what Spain is really like it's
not a beginning middle and ending it's
three medals three medals in there
cartoons the woman who ran the studio
that made this they try to unionize and
she got rid of the whole company instead
of unionizing and one of the guys who
worked there was last name was Barbara
he went on this trip he went on to make
hanna-barbera and he is the guy who came
up with Tom and Jerry so then his to see
he was like good lord it's been staring
me in the face the whole time there are
cat and mouse
yeah god bless it yeah basically okay so
I guess if you're in 1932 it just took a
lot less
[Music]